okay so I think this was a good
discussion and hopefully this got you
all thinking a little bit about some of
the pieces that we are going to talk
about next uh so which is basically
evaluating model interpretations and
explanations right
okay so uh so let's kind of think about
this first at a very high level right so
whenever we have some model
interpretations or explanations so we
want to evaluate two pieces the first
one is the meaningfulness or the
correctness of explanations or
interpretations right and the second one
is the interpretability of these
interpretations or explanations right so
both are important so as I think several
of you brought up if I give you an
explanation that's actually not being
used by the model in a very specific way
or it's an incorrect description of what
the model is actually doing that's very
bad and harmful actually because you
know now we are telling people that this
is what the model is doing and that's
not what it is doing that's probably
worser than not giving them anything
right and the second thing is you can
give people something but they need to
be able to look at it and make sense of
what that is right if it is too
complicated if I give you 200 million
parameters that's not going to be useful
even if it's a very accurate
representation of what the model is
doing okay
so let's talk a little bit about
evaluating interpretability so these are
two pieces evaluating the correctness or
meaningfulness and then evaluating
interpretability right so when it comes
to evaluating interpretability so here
are three classes of evaluation that was
suggested in one of the prior survey
papers so the first is functionally
grounded evaluation where you use some
kinds of quantitative proxy metrics
there are no real humans doing anything
with it but you use some proxy metrics
to determine the interpretability of a
given interpretation or explanation
right the second is human grounded
evaluation where there are people but
they are doing simpler tasks and not the
exact tasks that are done in an
application okay and then there is
application grounded evaluation which
basically is what you guys were pointing
out which is just sort of do as close to
possible to down stream tasks right so
let users do either the exact Downstream
task or something very close to it and
then see how much they're able to do it
so all of these can help with evaluating
the interpretability or probably more
broadly utility of these interpretations
and explanations right so just to give
some examples of each of these
functionally grounded evaluation the
proxy metrics could be something like
number of rules or number of prototypes
right just lower is better so there is
we are not doing any user studies we are
not doing any kind of human subject
evaluations here we are just saying less
things are better right so that's just a
rule of thumb by the way
and human grounded means you can think
of like two to three different kinds of
tasks here no recall that this is
basically a simplified version of human
evaluation right so either we force
people to make a choice so I give you
two explanations and then I say which
one is more easier for you to read right
so we force people to make a choice and
through that evaluate the
interpretability of these explanations
or interpretations the second one is
forward simulation or prediction which
means I give you the input the
explanation and then the output or sorry
the input and the explanation and I ask
you to predict the output of the model
right so you should look at the input
and the explanation and say oh I know
that the model or at least I can infer
that the model can predict a label one
for this instance right and the last one
is counterfactual simulation in that
case I'll give you the input data point
and then the explanation and people
should be able to tell what features
need to be changed in order for the
prediction to change of course this is
probably more obvious with some
explanations than others but you know
that's that's another sort of like a
proxy task that is used to evaluate uh
interpretability right so last one of
course is either let domain experts do
the exact application task or let domain
experts do a simpler version of the
application but in either case we are
testing with real users to see what is
going on right
okay
all right so let's talk a little bit
first about evaluating the inherently
interpretable models so here just kind
of you know sort of instantiating it for
this setup uh we want to evaluate the
accuracy of the resulting model because
these models are at the end of the day
you know classifiers or predictors right
so when evaluating inherently
interpretable models you want to see
what's the accuracy of the resulting
model you also want to evaluate the
interpretability of the resulting models
like for example prototypes so we get
those as interpretations we want to see
how understandable they are or even
attention weights and the last thing is
in this case and I think some of you
have probably answered this question uh
partly or indirectly so in this case do
we need to evaluate the correctness or
meaningfulness of the resulting
interpretations
what do you guys think
so it's an inherently interpretable
model right so since it's a model you're
evaluating its accuracy since it gives
you prototypes or weights you are saying
how interpretable are these but do I
need to evaluate the correctness of
those prototypes or
you know say the meaningfulness of those
prototypes or attention weights
or is it obvious like since it's coming
from the model it must be right or are
there some cases where it is obvious in
some cases where it's not because there
is a whole gamut of inherently
interpretable models
right
but if you actually believe that like
this is exactly uncomfortable
right
so if you're adding layers you might
want to check the output of what those
layers are producing that's what you're
saying so what do you think about like
in the beginning in the very beginning
we talked about some rule lists and Rule
sets what do you think about those do
those need some kind of correctness
evaluation for the interpretation
this correctness is probably fine but
like meaningful I guess yeah but what
exactly mean by correctness right so
when I say correctness for example if I
give you a prototype output by the
Prototype layer in the models that we
are considering in the Deep Nets
so should I just assume that oh I've
added a layer the model is giving me a
prototype apparently it's basing its
prediction on this prototype
and should I just accept that at face
value or should I need to probe that a
bit more
right but but would this answer change
if we were talking about say a rule list
maybe okay
yeah yeah just not even a postdoc
explanation like just the rule list is
the classifier
yeah
it's all there right yeah right so in
some sense for some of the very initial
models we talked about
everything is all there right like as
she's suggesting so you essentially the
five rules you have in your hand are the
model so that's what is used for
classification so maybe in that setting
this whole notion of evaluating the
correctness of the interpretation is not
really as relevant or important but the
moment we go to something like adding
layers to the models you might want to
double check what those layers are
learning and if they're even learning
something useful or meaningful right and
we'll talk a little bit about how some
of the prior Works have thought about
this particular part but hopefully the
rest two are like pretty obvious which
is accuracy of the entire model and
interpretability of these
interpretations okay
so yeah I think we did some of this
discussion already about this so
essentially my plan was to sort of go
over some of these and then say how do
we think about like evaluating the
accuracy or the interpretability of this
uh so maybe we can do a couple of these
and then I think we have discussed the
third point at length which is
correctness so I think in this case the
correctness of the interpretation is not
really something that we may question
much because this is essentially the
model right it is what it is again
whether it's causal or not you know it's
probably not but like we are not getting
into that right so accuracy of this
model I guess you can use this to
compute the labels for your test points
right and then get accuracy numbers of
this model and accuracy is what it is
right so uh I guess interpretability how
about evaluating interpretability on
this
would like number of rules and like you
know the downstream applications and
some of those things still hold here
like asking people to do predictions
based on this
do all of those seem like valid
approaches to test the interpretability
yeah that's right
I think we can argue something similar
for this also right so it's essentially
a slightly different form of
classification uh so that is that okay
so
uh one thing I wanted to show you here
is basically some kind of comparative
analysis between the rule lists and then
the decision sets right so while these
are almost seeming like very similar
models or at least in there the
constructs that they use they seem very
similar they can impact certain tasks
that we might ask people to do right so
one way to think about this is we can
just compare the number of rules and
predicates in these models and say
whichever is lower is better right the
other thing is as we were all discussing
let's do some user studies okay so one
of the user studies that was done and
what we did here was basically uh get a
bunch of users and each user will be
randomly assigned to one of the two
models either the rule lists or the
decision sets and each of them will
answer about 12 questions or 10
objective and then two descriptive
questions so the objective questions
look something like this so essentially
we say there is a patient with the 4
following medical record so we have
partial information about this patient
just using this partial information can
you be absolutely sure that the above
model will say that the patient suffers
from lung cancer right so questions like
these these are the objective questions
that we were asking so essentially give
partial information and see if people
can you know correctly ascribe the
prediction of that model uh you know to
basically the point that we are thinking
about
and the next one is a descriptive
question where we say so write a short
paragraph describing the characteristics
of asthma patients based on these rules
provided above right so they have to
just describe in plain English what are
the characteristics of asthma patient
according to the rules given uh so what
we observe is actually something
interesting for these two specific tasks
right so we have seen that this kind of
unordered rules are actually helping
people give answers to those questions
that we are asking much more accurately
and in a much more faster way both the
objective as well as the descriptive
questions so in some sense even
something as small as having an elsif
structure which requires you to unroll
the previous rules and then say Oh if
that does not apply and then I come here
that logic is already
cognitively taxing to people in doing
certain tasks right like in the kinds of
questions that we were asking so that
kind of shows that even simple changes
to visualizations or constructs can have
a big impact when you think about
Downstream tasks are interpretability
okay all right so let's talk about this
prototype and attention layers I think
which we already kicked off so I think
several of you are thinking that there
is no guarantee that these prototypes
and attention weights are going to be
meaningful uh so what do we do about it
right so one of the prior works by Jane
and Wallace they actually check
if attention weights correlate with
other measures of feature importance for
example gradients uh and they also check
if we were to give different attention
weights would they yield in different
predictions so they do two kinds of
checks to determine the correctness or
meaningfulness of these attention
weights okay and the answer turns out to
be no in both cases
uh so neither are these attention
weights learned by the attention layers
of the model correlating with the
gradients of the model uh with respect
to input points Nar is changing the
attention weights to different values
changing prediction significantly
um so this paper basically raised a lot
of questions about this whole notion of
let's add some layers and make models
inherently interpretable and then
everything will get solved right because
the complexity of these models is such
that I think the way people are just
combining different things adding a
layer and saying this will take care of
everything that's unfortunately not
turning out to be true
right okay
so let's talk a little bit about
evaluating post-hoc explanations right
and under uh this category so you could
think of several aspects that can be
quantitatively evaluated and some
aspects that you know have to be
qualitatively evaluated or through user
studies right
um so first is of course evaluating the
faithfulness or correctness of post-hoc
explanations and we'll discuss that in
detail next is evaluating the stability
of post-hoc explanations which is when
you make small input perturbations how
much do the explanations change right
third is evaluating the fairness of
post-hoc explanations which means is the
accuracy of explanations kind of roughly
similar for majority and minority groups
right or are the explanations for
instances in a majority group much more
accurate than the explanations for
instances in minority group if so there
is some weird kind of of unfairness or
bias that is kicking in there right and
lastly evaluating the interpretability
of the post-hoc explanations
okay so let's go piece by piece and you
know this is actually like this entire
sort of setup of all these evaluations
as part of one of our recent Benchmark
papers which I'll also discuss a little
bit at the end of this uh you know okay
so evaluating faithfulness of post-talk
explanations again there are different
ways to do it depending on the kind of
information you have available right so
for example let's say that you have some
ground truth information available and
that ground truth could come in the form
of here are the top K features or that
the model is using when making these
kinds of predictions and I know for a
fact that those are the features the
model is using right if such a ground
truth exists then you could basically
think of several sort of agreement
metrics in the top K features and also
generally if you are able to rank
features in some order of importance you
can use that ground root to sort of
determine how accurate your different
kinds of explanations are right so for
example you can think of this as feature
agreement which is the fraction of the
top K features output by your
explanation how many of those actually
appear in the top care features of the
ground truth right or you can say rank
agreement not only should this features
that are appearing in the top key of
explanation appear in the ground truth
but the rank ordering of these features
should also match the ground truth then
I consider it as there is a rank
agreement right and you can make them
stricter like for example sign agreement
could be that the sign whether it's a
positive contribution or a negative even
within the top five features or top K
features that should match sign rank
agreement basically the sign should
match rank should match the features
should appear everything happens then
it's a perfect match right so you could
think of like a bunch of these kinds of
things or you could also think of rank
correlation coefficients if you are
given a ground truth or coloring of
features somehow if you're given you
know your explanation ordering of
features then you can compute rank
correlation coefficients you could even
compute pairwise rank agreement which is
basically take two features at a time
and then see if the ordering of those
two features is maintained between the
explanation learned and the ground truth
explanation right so these are all the
things that you can do if there is some
notion of ground truth and some notion
of ordering among the features in that
ground truth okay
is there a question yeah
that are we evaluating the correctness
of Are We evaluating how good our
explanation is or are we testing how
good our model was and then later my uh
essentially I could have had a bad model
but a good explanation on top of it
right that explanation would save these
tests because the model itself did not
pick up right so let me clarify the
notion of ground truth here right so
when I'm using the term ground truth
here I don't mean it's a ground truth
associated with the data I mean it's the
ground truth associated with the model
right for example if your underlying
model is a logistic regression you know
the answer for what are the top K
features of that model
right so you take that and that is your
ground truth so just to yeah so this
ground truth should not be confused with
the ground truth of the data this is the
ground truth of the model if we know the
ground truth of the model then we can
apply these metrics
[Music]
like how do I find out for a more
complex
yeah so this is basically the case where
your models are simple and you are able
to do this right so we are going to come
to different we are going to relax that
assumption right so this is a very basic
case wherever you have ground truth
available of the model we can
potentially use this in fact in one of
our papers I don't think we have too
much discussion in this about it but we
can create synthetic data sets
which sort of create these islands of
data points that are farther away and
fit a linear model on each eyelid
so we know for a fact that there is one
linear model operating on this island of
data points and that will give you the
ground truth feature importances for
that Island
and we have some theorems and conditions
that need to be satisfied and any
accurate model that you train on these
synthetic data sets will have to respect
these feature importances across these
islands right but this is only possible
because we are able to generate
synthetic data sets yeah okay
all right uh so now we we are going to
the next condition where we don't have
ground truth but our explanations
themselves are models right so for
example lime is basically fitting a
linear model on some local neighborhood
right so if the explanation itself is a
model we can basically take the
explanation model and then get
predictions of that model on instances
in the local neighborhood and we can
compare how these predictions match with
the predictions of the underlying model
right so you have one model which is
your explanation model your one model
which is the underlying model compare
what fraction of the predictions of
these two models match in a given local
neighborhood right and the higher the
match basically the more accurate the
explanation that's one notion of
thinking about faithfulness when your
explanations themselves are models okay
so now the question is what if we don't
have any ground truth right and what if
explanation that we are looking at
cannot be considered as models at output
predictions okay
so for that we have again some tricks so
one of the basic idea here is remove
important features as designated by the
explanation and see what happens right
so for example here is you know an image
and we have constructed some
explanations on this and according to
the explanations there are a bunch of
important features keep removing those
from that image right so keep removing
the important features one after the
other from the image and see how the
prediction probability drops okay and in
some sense if removing the top five
important features from the image as
given by an explanation causes a bigger
drop in the prediction probability than
some other explanations top five
features the first one is better because
those important features are somehow
capturing more of the predictive power
right so that's the idea essentially
okay yep
what do you mean by like removing so if
you like if you check I mean if you
change the color yeah you pick up a
different picture rather than like you
don't really remember yeah yeah so in
some sense this is where the notion of
background distribution comes into
picture so often for each data set
people basically have and this can be
selected either through like you know
pursuing data or like looking at data or
using some computational methods as well
but essentially you can you kind of come
up with in this data set given the
nature of images may be replacing
something by black means I'm removing
that feature quote and code right so
that's one way to think about it the
other way to think about it if such a
notion of background distribution is not
coming out naturally is part of the
values of those pixels so you have some
values RGB values just add a bunch of
noise to them okay and when you add that
noise your prediction should change if
those features are important right
yep yeah yeah yeah
it depends on so typically as I was
saying so there is think of it as for
each data set there could be some
background image which basically is like
a no signal image right so if we are
able to get to that then you are truly
removing a feature otherwise you are
merely changing something you have there
to something else but the idea is still
the same if a feature is important and
if you mess with it the prediction
should change drastically
right
okay so that's that's one piece of it
and then the other piece of it is you
know insertion or like adding important
features and seeing what happens right
so for example if this is the background
image uh so then essentially you keep
adding features and then seeing how much
sort of the prediction probability
changes right uh in some sense I would
think of it as take there are two sides
to it right so take important features
perturb them and if you're perturbing
important features really your
predictions should change the
alternative is take unimportant features
perturb them if your prediction is
changing then that's bad because your
unimportant features are carrying signal
right so those are roughly the two ways
of thinking about you know how to
evaluate the faithfulness of
explanations uh but when doing this
evaluation I think it's useful to think
of it as a comparative one right so I
don't know if it's absolutely
good if I get some value of drop in
probability but if there are two
explanations where one has a higher drop
in probability than other when I'm
removing important features or you know
perturbing them then this explanation is
better than the other right so it at
least helps you place explanations
relatively in terms of their
faithfulness okay
all right so the next aspect is
stability uh so our post talk
explanation stable with respect to small
input perturbations right so to this end
like this was one of the first metrics
proposed and the idea what's going on
here is that you are Computing the
maximum change in explanation
relative to the change in the instances
so if you take an instance x i perturb
it a bit and do this like several times
and then you calculate the maximum
change in the explanation divided by uh
the change in the points or the distance
between the points so then you will
basically get a value for what is the
maximum possible change in explanation
in a given small Epsilon ball
neighborhood right so the higher this
value the more unstable the
corresponding explanation is considered
okay
um so that's that's one part that's a
metric so now there are a bunch of other
questions that sort of come out here
right so what if the underlying model
itself is unstable in the sense that if
I make a small perturbation to the point
the prediction of the model itself
changes then in that case my explanation
should change right like it's just
reflecting Model Behavior so to account
for that there are a couple more metrics
and some of our recent works one is you
also account in the denominator for the
change in the output prediction
probabilities are you in fact account
for the changes in the intermediate
representations of the model uh as you
sort of perturb instances right and the
change in your explanation should be
proportionate to some of these changes
and that's when it is sort of considered
stable because you're also accounting
for the models properties in there okay
all right so fairness of post-hoc
explanations so really fairness of
postdoc explanations is about taking all
your faithfulness metrics stability
metrics and Computing the mean values of
those metrics for a majority Group by
averaging all those metrics or instances
in the majority group and the minority
group and seeing if the two means are
different in a statistically significant
way right if there is a difference then
there is potentially unfairness because
for example think of a health care
situation where there are a bunch of
explanations for men and a bunch of
explanations for women about how they
are getting diagnosed with a disease
right if the women's explanations are
looking correct but are actually
incorrect
they are not faithful the doctor might
just rely on them and make decisions
according to those and have no idea that
you know those explanations are in fact
incorrect whereas one group's
explanations are correct right so it can
cause all kinds of issues in practice so
this is also undesirable in some sense
so your accuracies across different
subgroups that you care about with
respect to explanations should not be
significantly different okay so why and
when can such unfairness occur or you
know you don't have to give all the sort
of sufficient conditions but any
intuition about when such unfairness can
occur so when can explanations be more
accurate for let's say male subgroup and
less accurate for female subgroup when
does that happen
yeah
on the one subgroup you mean wherever
there's like I think you're sort of in
the ballpark so lack of data about one
subgroup
any other thoughts
okay so how about we think of this
scenario so for example let's say we are
using line right so what is lime doing
lime is trying to fit a local linear
model at each point which is explaining
its prediction right so now when is that
local linear model more accurate for one
group than the other right
so maybe the underlying model is
actually a linear model for instance
this in one subgroup and it's actually a
non-linear model for instances in the
other subgroup right so potentially the
differences in the model surface and the
ability of your explanation methods to
capture those model surfaces can cause
this unfairness right so it's really you
know it's not a big devil in there it's
the fact that you are trying to fit a
linear model now your underlying model
is linear in some parts of the feature
space and is non-linear in other parts
so you are just getting a better fit in
some parts than the other right so
that's when unfairness can happen but
it's important to be mindful of
something like this because it can
affect how correct your explanations are
okay all right so this is something that
we have just looked at earlier just kind
of bringing that back into the
foreground because we are going to talk
about interpretability and how to
evaluate it for postdoc explanations
okay so
the first one is essentially forward
simulation so essentially you will show
a new data point to the user the user
may also have access to past predictions
and explanations but for this new data
point you basically show the explanation
to the user and then you are trying to
make the user guess the prediction of
the model based on this instance and its
explanation and you will compare the
accuracy of the user or rather you
compare the label assigned to the
instance by the user with that of the
label assigned by the model right so if
those both match then the user is
accurate or they are able to simulate
the model okay so this was something
that was done in one of the studies by
Microsoft research so essentially they
showed people instances their
corresponding explanations and tried to
ask them questions like what do you
think this model will predict how
confident are you that the model will
predict this and so on right so these
are the kinds of tasks that people
typically do in this setting right or
there is even more sort of like you know
the next level of tasks in terms of
complexity where you will check for the
effectiveness of human AI collaboration
right so again as some of you are
pointing out Downstream applications are
these explanations useful for making
decisions right where algorithms are not
uh by themselves reliable so for example
uh there are some studies which
basically do this with tasks like
detection deception detection which is
identifying fake reviews online uh so if
you give explanations to humans as they
are identifying fake views online will
it help right so that was the kind of
task that was done and yeah so the
results in some of these tasks are
actually positive for this particular
task people did find our researchers did
find that you know with explanations
humans were able to identify fake
reviews online much better than without
so this is one of our recent studies and
this has been in the making for a long
time because it involves access to
doctors and you know people who are
actually domain experts in healthcare uh
so what we were doing was we were trying
to work with the setting of a prediction
problem uh where we ask a bunch of
doctors a question a prediction question
which is I'll give you the patient's
current health record uh in terms of
their current symptoms you know their
previous medical history family medical
history all of that stuff and you have
to predict if this patient is likely to
be diagnosed with breast cancer within
the next two years right so there's not
a diagnosis problem it's a forecasting
problem right so we basically carried
out studies with about 78 doctors who
are residents in Internal Medicine in
hospitals in Boston and each doctor so
this is an online user study each doctor
looks at 10 patient records from
historical data and make predictions on
them right so none of this is live we
are just kind of mocking the situation
that they might you know encounter in
their practice but we are doing this
with historical data okay
so what we found was something
interesting so if we let just doctors
make this prediction on their own with
in fact no models their accuracy of
predicting somebody's chances of getting
breast cancer accurately is about 78
right if we give them the prediction of
the model so instead of just the doctor
we say okay for that individual it's a
label of at-risk with a probability of
0.91 okay so if we give that much just
that part and the models accuracy in
this case is about 89 what we found was
something very interesting the combined
accuracy of the doctor along with model
predictions is actually worser than the
model's accuracy
uh and I'll talk a little bit about why
but I think that's not the central point
of this discussion but then there was a
third condition where there was a doctor
we showed the prediction the prediction
probability and also the top four
important features that went into the
prediction where we evaluated the
faithfulness of these and picked the
method that was giving the highest
faithfulness according to this perturb
important and unimportant features
metrics okay so in that case the
accuracy shot up quite a bit
uh so we are trying to do this study on
a bit larger scale but like yeah
essentially this is with real doctors
but you know a task that is close enough
to their uh day-to-day decision making
right so that's one thing that I wanted
to point about and you know the the
reason why that could happen is
potentially there are also instances
where people are seeing that the
important features are things like those
appointment time they zip code you know
some of these curious features and in
those cases doctors are able to say I
don't want to rely on the model
prediction make my own decision
right okay yep
yeah so did you try to kind of have a
control experiment where are you okay
you're having a dog you have your doctor
and the neural network output but you
tell a lie like not not what the neural
network said you put a random number and
you see what the doctors would give yeah
so what we did was we did not do that
with the models or predictions but we
did it with explanations
so what if we could just randomly pick
top four features and give it to the
doctor would that actually help improve
their decision making as like is it just
the concept of explanation or is it a
correct explanation and turns out it is
the correct explanation in fact what we
have seen is if if I just pick randomly
top four features and say here is
explanation uh and if doctors look at it
and make decisions based on that their
performance is kind of much worser uh
than what they would sometimes I think
in like we are trying to replicate this
across different hospitals but at least
in one hospital it's actually worser
than what it would have been had they
just have access to nothing at all
so bad explanations are going to hurt
very badly so that's the moral of that
story yeah
something they tend to trust the neural
network so basically they tend to trust
the science the computer science right
well I think that should depend on
whether the model itself is sure about
the prediction or what it is doing also
right but yeah that's a good point
yeah in the last row
um you said that you're giving an
explanation about the important features
but they're not actually important
features not not in this set none of
these numbers are with the uh bad
explanations or randomly chosen
explanations
it's only the accurate explanations yeah
Okay so yeah these were just
clarifications of like how those numbers
are coming by the way okay
so uh let's kind of zoom out a bit and
you know several of you already
mentioned challenges of that evaluating
these kinds of interpretations or
explanations is challenging so why
because first of all this is actually an
ongoing Endeavor and what are the
challenges associated with that one
thing that needs to be kept in mind is
parameter settings or hyper parameters
influence the resulting interpretations
or explanations right so given that we
need to be very careful about those
settings and what we are using because
for example in line while we did not
look at the objective per se so the
objective function has two terms so one
of it is it's basically trying to fit a
linear model that matches the
predictions of the underlying model the
second term is a regularizer term where
it is trying to reduce the number of
features for which the coefficient
weights are non-zero right so
essentially depending on the trade-off
parameter you set there you might get
different answers or essentially even if
you change the number of perturbations
you might get different answers right so
there are all these things that need to
be kept in mind when thinking about you
know the explanations that are being
generated okay so one approach can
generate different explanations
depending on the parameter settings you
are producing or providing right and the
second thing is there is as we have seen
there is a whole lot of diversity in
terms of what is a basic unit of
interpretation you know what is the
method doing for example there are a
bunch of methods all of which produce
feature importances like lime shop Maple
gradient based methods all of those
they're giving you some numbers
indicating the importance of features
right but they're all using seemingly
diverse approaches to do that like one
is fitting a linear model one is trying
to get to shapely values one is trying
to compute gradients the other is trying
to smooth gradient so they're all doing
like a lot of have different kinds of
things right so given this diversity in
approaches and the constructs like how
do we even think about comparisons so we
have to come up with diverse metrics
which is also non-trivial and user
studies can themselves be inconsistent
because they're often affected by the
choice of UI phrasing visualization the
population that you are considering if
you're giving any incentives to people
to do these tasks and so on right so
there are all these things to be kept in
mind which is why some of the results
that we discuss and I do talk about like
why we are getting like mixed
conclusions about the utility or
interpretability of some of these
methods is because of this since it is
still and you know ongoing active area
of research and things are still being
figured out right
okay
so I want to kind of just talk a little
bit about some of the currently
available open source tool for
quantitative evaluation so none of these
are for user studies so these are just
quantitative evaluations if you are
thinking about inherently interpretable
models so there is this interpret ml uh
you know GitHub repo and also Online
Library which can be useful with a bunch
of inherently interpretable models
including Gams and Rule lists and sets
and all of that so then there are a
bunch of xai libraries for different
things for example captain from Facebook
has a lot of implementations of
different uh explanation post hoc
explanation methods uh then there are
some of the benchmarks like eraser is a
good Benchmark for explanations on NLP
so we have this Library called openxai
which is basically like 22 metrics all
the things that we discussed state of
the art metrics we are also having some
public dashboards for comparing you know
explanation methods on different kinds
of data sets and so on so it's pretty
easy to use some of these Frameworks
actually both open XA and Qantas you can
use with 11 lines of code you'll be able
to evaluate uh you know different
explanation methods that are supported
by these packages right so things are
getting there but whether we have
correct answers conclusive insights and
inferences that's another question I
think that's going to take some time
okay all right so we have actually a bit
more time so I'm going to jump into the
next part which is trying to sort of
think about the insights that we have
about the behavior of different
inherently interpretable models and post
hoc exploration methods okay
all right any questions so far sorry
maybe I'll pause here and see yep
very often we get very different results
Great questions so your question is if
we use different explanation methods if
I get different results what do I do
right that's a great question we are
going to touch upon that quite a bit in
this part okay yep
all right yes
we should get different results because
we can have multiple explanations yep
for the same time
um so you're saying different methods
are giving different answers that does
not have to be bad
it's not the same method same method
okay
right so your question is if even if I
just use lime and if I just set the
number of perturbations to different
values if lime gives different
explanations why is that bad right so
we'll get to that in a bit uh so there
is something fuzzy about this particular
aspect if I set the number of
perturbations to different values if I'm
getting different explanations
the most likely answer is the
explanation method has not converged to
an expected explanation so how do we
think about that of course if you change
the parameters like for example the
Lambda which balances the regularization
term with the last term and so on then
you can get different explanations right
so one is you know having less non-zero
coefficient uh associated with features
that there is more accurate in terms of
the model it is fitting and so on but
we'll get to this discussion this is
exactly what is the next part okay
all right okay
so let's get into this
uh so there is a lot of recent focus on
analyzing the behavior of post-hoc
explanation methods uh and there are a
bunch of empirical studies analyzing the
faithfulness and stability fairness
adversarial vulnerabilities utility of
post-hoc explanation methods and a lot
of these studies also demonstrate the
limitations of existing post-hoc
explanation methods right so this is a
very active area of research uh
personally this kind of empirical and
theoretical analysis is something that
I'm like very keen on and like
constitutes a bunch of our current work
and we'll talk about some of the
theoretical results and empirical
results and so on okay
so this is actually a paper by Julius
adebayo at all in 2018 uh what they were
trying to test is basically they were
trying to see if gradient-based
explanations are any good which is
basically you know input gradient input
times gradient smooth grad integrated
grad all the things that we were talking
about so they were checking if those
explanations are any good and the tests
that they did was that they started
randomizing the parameters of the model
of deep neural networks starting all the
way from the top layer that is closer to
the softmax layer and all the way till
like the bottom layer okay so as they
randomized each layer what they realized
is that the explanations are not really
changing with these methods especially a
couple of them I think well even
gradient times input has that problem
but like it's more pronounced with some
of the other methods which basically
means no matter what the parameters on
your network are somehow these methods
are trying to give you the same answer
and that is particularly happening with
some of these methods because I think
some of you were already pointing to
your discussion there so some of these
methods are trying to guide or bias the
explanations generated to something that
is likely to be intuitive to the users
right because a lot of times people are
like you know oh we should get an ex you
know explanation that's less noisy
that's more meaningful all that is
amazing but it's only amazing when your
model is also doing that right but if
your model is not doing it and you're
sort of guiding your explanations to do
it then you will have beautiful
explanations for a model that's bad
right so that's what is kind of
happening with some of these approaches
uh so basically they're failing the
model parameter randomization test
okay
and
the next thing that they tried is that
they basically randomized the class
labels of instances so they took the
data set they randomized the class
labels of the instances and you know had
a different model and even that really
did not impact the explanations right so
this is bad so basically changes in
model are not being reflected in the
changes in explanation at all right for
some methods more than others right
mostly those guided sort of methods that
are being used
okay so we talked a little bit about
stability uh we asked the question or at
least we saw this metric earlier and we
were thinking if post hoc explanations
are unstable with respect to small
non-adversarial input perturbations
uh turns out approaches like lime can be
unstable so these approaches are relying
on perturbation based uh perturbations
basically they create perturbations of
an instance and try to fit a model on
those so they are more likely to be
unstable than some of the other gradient
based methods so that's one of the
finding in one of the studies and this
is true uh even when the underlying
model whether it's prediction or whether
it is representations those are not
changing much so even when they're not
changing much the explanation is
changing drastically with some of these
methods for example like
uh so there is I think one of you raised
the question just now about you know
different explanations uh coming out
from the same method right uh so I just
want to highlight this example a bit and
this is one of our works a couple of
years back is that so what we see in
this image you know maybe I'll focus on
the last two pictures so the underlying
model is a non-linear model
and in figure C the number of
perturbations is high and in figure D
the number of perturbations is low
so when the number of perturbations is
high and if I keep repeatedly re-running
line with the same number of
perturbations I get kind of similar
answers in terms of explanation okay but
when the number of perturbations is low
and if I keep re-running lime on the
same point with the same parameters I
get varied answers in terms of the
explanations that lime outputs right so
indicating the potential that you know
with fewer samples or fewer
perturbations the method has potentially
not converged so there is effect on the
perturbations you pick on the
explanation that you get right whereas
if you increase that number this this
chance reduces and you are likely to get
similar explanations right so that's one
possible way to think about it but if we
I think the point that I'm trying to
make is that we need to be very careful
about setting the parameters in these
methods because these kinds of issues
can happen right
uh so here what this is sort of bringing
up is an important question which is
okay so maybe there's a problem with
having too few perturbations right so
then the question is what is the optimal
number of perturbations
okay so that is some of you know the
recent research which I'll touch upon as
we are thinking about some of the future
directions okay
all right so some are findings right so
some of the recent works also identified
that post-hoc explanations can be easily
manipulated so just to show you an
example uh so here is the original image
you know here is the explanation
generated here is the manipulated image
you kind of changed it uh very slightly
in an almost imperceptible way for a
human eye and this is the explanation
right so in some sense you know for
those of you familiar with adverse
serial examples literature for generic
machine learning models this analogous
to that in the explanation literature
right
so essentially this paper and also the
next paper they're trying to do
something very similar what they're
trying to do is find the smallest
perturbation to the input image that can
help maximally change the explanation
and also kind of anchor it to some
misleading explanations that you know an
adversary would want the approach to
generate right so that's possible that
is doable of course whether adversaries
will have that kind of access in
practice or not you know that's a
separate issue but you know you can if
if you were an adversary with a lot of
control uh and can run all these things
you could potentially do that right
right so another one of uh recent Works
was basically about trying to design
scaffolding attacks to hide classifiers
dependence on certain bad features so
essentially what you see here in this
picture is that there is a biased
classifier that we created which was
essentially completely using gender to
make its decisions on in-sample data
points okay on the data distribution and
then uh the attack I'll talk about in a
bit what the attack is but once we do
the attack that is the explanation
generated by line and line completely
thinks that we are using some loan rate
feature as the main feature so it's not
even detecting that like gender is being
used predominantly similar thing with
shap uh it's not able to detect that
gender is being used predominantly it's
thinking some other innocent innocuous
feature is being used right so what did
we do here uh I'll explain the attack
just in a bit but essentially this
attack is exploiting one intuition about
the behavior of lime and shap so while
we talked about perturbations in line
the initial version of line essentially
does binary perturbations what I mean by
that is it kind of you know transforms
the input feature space to something
that is just binary so every feature
will just have a one or zero value and
when it does a perturbation it basically
flips once to zeros by choosing features
randomly which have one values okay so
it just does the flipping of ones and
zeros when it does perturbations
now in doing that what happens is if I
were to so this is actually the compass
data set what we did is took the
instances of the compass data set did a
PCA projected them onto these two
Dimensions First Dimension of PC on the
x-axis second dimension on the y-axis
and you can see the original Compass
instances in blue Compass is a data set
that people often use in this community
for thinking about criminal justice
tasks for example right it has its fair
share of issues but nevertheless it is a
popular data set so blue is the original
instances from the data and the red is
the perturbations generated by Lyman
shop okay so the Insight from this is uh
a lot of the perturb data points are
actually out of distribution
uh so that is happening and I think in
fact this resonates with the question or
discussion some of you were also
mentioning so what I why do I say this
is because I can actually construct
accurate classifiers that separate that
can nicely separate points that are
perturbations from points that are in
the data so those are separable right so
those are in some sense uh distinctly
sort of perceivable at least by models
okay so because of that the intuition
here is that adversaries can sort of
exploit this notion or intuition and
build a classifier that is highly biased
on in-sample data points and is unbiased
on out of distribution samples right so
if I just create a classifier which is
using race or gender through and through
on the in Sample points and is using
loan rate and income and other you know
legit features on the out of sample
perturbations then the fact that these
approaches rely so heavily on
perturbations means they'll not be able
to see what is happening in Sample
they'll just assume that the model is
just doing whatever it is doing out of
sample perturbations
right so that is basically the attack or
the intuition behind it so essentially
you can think of the setting as
adversaries want to deploy some biased
classifier in real world example this
classifier will just use race to make
decisions so adversary must provide
Black Box access to customers and
Regulators who may use post hoc
techniques like lime or shap as mandated
by gdpr they need to provide that query
access so the goal of adversary is to
fool post-hoc explanation techniques and
hide the underlying biases of these
models right so to that end essentially
the adversary can create this kind of a
classifier where if the point is in the
distribution uh the adversarial
classifier will return the label of the
biased classifier if the point is not in
the distribution which is out of
distribution perturbation the
adversarial classifier will return the
output of a unbiased classifier which
uses the legitimate features right so
that kind of scaffolding attack can
already fool a lot of the these kinds of
algorithms okay
all right
okay so we discuss this okay
so another thing that we slightly
touched upon is there were also studies
which kind of showed that explanations
can be highly sensitive to random uh
hyper parameters including random seeds
right so we went through some of the
number of perturbations and so on but
random seeds and even that kind of patch
sizes and so on those hyper parameters
are also going to influence the kinds of
explanations you generate and it's
important to keep that in mind as we
think about this but by the way just to
also not make it super scandalous these
kinds of things are probably true with a
lot of things we do in machine learning
okay that hasn't really stopped us from
doing that anyway so there is no sort of
villain here in post-hoc explanations I
think this is just how the field is
going and you know sort of moving
forward whether it's you know perfect
not really but you know that's the
status quo it's not specific to
explainability I just want to say that
okay
um so this is one of our other studies
that's actually hinting at what some of
you were pointing out which is uh so
there is there is a way in which we as
machine learning researchers think of
what an explanation means and what a
domain expert let's say in healthcare or
lock and think of explanations to me
right so for example what we did was
like this kind of a simple online user
study with a bunch of law school
students at Harvard uh the task was you
know sort of bail adjudication which is
there is a classifier that basically is
predicting if somebody is risky enough
to be released on bail so whether
they're risky or not and what we did was
so this is the classifier so this is the
true classifier it relies on race and
it's clearly discriminating this is a
very bad classifier and
we constructed a high fidelity
misleading Global explanation for this
so essentially what we did was ensure
that all the features like race and
gender be removed when we construct that
explanation so we are so if you guys
recall so we were constructing Global
explanations using rules earlier and
that's an explanation constructed using
one of those approaches it'll
approximate this very accurately so if
you take the prediction match uh
whatever predictions that makes
accurately match with the predictions
made by this but if you see it is
relying on different features right so
what we did was essentially take a bunch
of law school students assign some of
them to see this true classifier assign
some of them to see that explanation and
then ask them the question of if this is
what your classifier is doing or I guess
the more precise question was if here is
an explanation generated by state of the
art method for the underlying model
would you trust this enough to deploy or
at least consider deploying this kind of
a model so unsurprisingly if you show
this model most of them were like nope
this is bad it's using race it's using
gender it's not it's a no-go right but
if we show that they're like oh okay so
it seems to be using reasonable features
I use prior FTA I use prior RS I use the
criminal status of the person so it's
using all the features that I would use
so yeah why not like I mean at least
consider deploying it right so this is
again sort of the gap between they're
assuming that an explanation will sort
of be causal in some sense right at
least with respect to the model but
that's not how all explanations are
constructed right so that is a problem
so in fact people are likely to trust
that the underlying model with that
explanation 10 times more than uh an
underlying model with this explanation
so
okay and there are also a bunch of other
studies which basically demonstrate that
uh post-hoc explanations can instill
over trust so for example there is a
nice study done by Microsoft research
and Harman preetkar so they showed that
domain experts and end users
first of all they are not entirely
understanding what these explanations
are doing and second of all Whenever
there is explanation they're kind of
over trusting the underlying model no
matter what the explanation is right uh
so in some sense they actually did these
interviews with data scientists uh and
there are several interesting quotes but
essentially what they sort of you know
infer from their studies that
participations are trusting their tools
because of their fancy visualizations
and they're well documented uh GitHub
packages
to put it very bluntly right so here are
some quotes from that study uh thing let
me see which is a good one
so yeah this for example this last one
the tool shows visualization of ml
models which is not something anything
else I've worked with has done it's very
transparent and that's why I trust it
more
right
so I think again there is there's a big
gap between how I think the research
Community is thinking about
interpretability and how practitioners
even data scientists you don't have to
go to doctors or judges or lawyers like
even data scientists are you know not
fully on board with what these
approaches are doing and there is a huge
risk that they're over trusting some of
these things
okay
all right uh so I think maybe I'll cover
this part a bit and then we can go for a
break uh so then there is the question
of utility right so a lot of times when
we are motivating whether it's
interpretations or explanations we are
basically saying that oh these are
useful for debugging for instance so one
of the study done with the housing price
prediction task uh basically
demonstrates that Amazon Mechanical
turkers are unable to really use linear
model coefficients to capture or
diagnose the mistakes that the model is
making right but then you could argue
that you know it's a very general
population they may not even interpret
these coefficients or model well which
is reasonable but like this is our
finding right and similarly uh I think
there is another paper that came out in
2020 which showed that in a particular
animal breed classification task users
familiar with machine learning are
relying on labels instead of saliency
maps for diagnosing model errors right
but that said there is one thing you
know which I would hint to take with a
pinch of salt uh so the evidence at this
point is really mixed so in some cases
we are seeing that these whether it's
model interpretations or explanations
are adding value and they're improving
something about the decision making
processes in some cases we are seeing
contrary evidence right so I think
that's why I was also highlighting to
one of our prior questions that I think
there is a need for like a clearer
characterization there is a need for
more standardized experimentation and
benchmarking so that at least you know
we understand that okay if I use these
settings if I do this exactly this is
the result that I would get right or
under these conditions these are the
results that I would get I think that
understanding currently is not there
it's of course an evolving field so we
are still trying to figure out what are
the best practices you know how to go
about these things but currently the
evidence and favor are against uh these
approaches are kind of mixed
so I think I'll pause here and then we
can continue this discussion at 3 pm
does that sound good
thank you guys
good
all right
okay all right uh welcome back everyone
so this is our last uh or last part of
this session thanks for sticking since
morning so I think we are almost at the
tail end of it
uh so let's kind of jump back to what we
were discussing right when we took the
break so we were talking about utility
and you know thinking about how post-hoc
explanations are being used in practice
like what are people finding and so on
right so this is again some of like the
very recent work out in 2022 by some of
students in our group
so the idea here is to basically you
know sort of think about I think at an
abstract level we are all able to see
that different post talk explanation
methods are generating potentially
different looking explanations right so
what are the implications of that like
are people able to understand that there
are these differences and perceive them
appropriately right so what we did here
was essentially a bunch of like studies
with practitioners data scientists this
time working in some of the you know
Tech startups which actually focus on
explainability uh so there is like a
direct Connection in terms of you know
these people you know sort of using
these tools in a very regular basis okay
uh we did a bunch of semi-structured
interviews like 30-minute
semi-structured interviews with about 25
data scientists uh and several of them
like precisely 84 of them actually said
that they encountered disagreement
between the explanations output by these
methods almost on a consistent basis
what's also interesting is they actually
say that they typically run not just one
but multiple methods when they have to
try to understand what are the features
or you know what is the explanation of
the model behavior for a particular
prediction okay so how are they thinking
about disagreement because we are saying
okay these explanations all look
different you know there's something
different about them but can we
precisely characterized disagreement and
according to these people here is how
they think about this agreement right
and this also boils down to some of the
faithfulness metrics that we saw
initially when we talked about if there
is ground truth feature importances of
the model right so according to these
people they think two explanations are
disagreeing if the top features in the
explanation are different so if I ask
for a top K feature list and two
explanation methods are giving me
different answers you know they consider
that it is agreement and the ordering
among the top features is different and
the direction which is the positive or
negative side of contribution of these
top features is different or even the
relative ordering of certain features of
interest is different right so okay so
now they're saying yeah we see a lot of
differences you know this is how we
think of a difference this is how we
think two explanations would qualify as
being different right so what do they do
to resolve these disagreements so if you
run two methods you see different
answers what do you do right the answer
is actually not not so optimistic one or
a positive one so what we did was a
study to actually see how they are
breaking the ties or you know what what
they do to proceed from this scenario of
disagreement okay so we short these
users explanations that disagree
according to their own definitions of
disagreement and ask them to make a
choice as to which explanation they
would pick and why okay
so they're choosing methods due to the
following factors
Associated Theory or publication time so
if a paper has more theory in the method
that it is proposing for some reason
that becomes more authentic or correct
or authoritative than the other or if
it's more recently published then that's
more likely to be correct or if the
explanations match your own intuition
better of what the model should do then
they're potentially picking such
explanations or you know types of data
for example if it's tabular data I'll
probably use Lyman Chapin or gradient
based methods right so here are some
codes and as you can see the factors
that we just talked about are sort of
sprinkled across these codes and you
will you know see them because it says
chap is a more rigorous approach than
lime you know as it has Theory or in
theory at least right so things like
that but the aspect of oh maybe we
should evaluate the faithfulness of
these two explanations and compare them
somehow or what about stability or
fairness so those are not popping up as
the things that they would do to pick
one explanation over the other and that
is concern right so in some sense there
are gaps between how research in these
areas is progressing versus like how
practitioners are taking all these tools
and trying to do something with them in
their day-to-day work and sort of it's
kind of we are bordering on all these
kinds of issues which are clearly
undecidable right uh so that's that's
yet another sort of cautionary tale to
sort of bridge the gap between research
that is happening and also the
practitioner Community okay so in
summary uh what we have seen is that a
lot of these empirical studies or
analysis are showing that some
explanation methods do not reflect or
Faithfully capture the behavior of the
underlying model some of these
explanation methods can be easily
manipulated slight changes to inputs can
cause blood changes and explanation
particularly for methods that use
perturbations like lime their utility in
practice is something that we still need
to sort of think more about right
so that's one part of it and on the this
we are talking a lot about explanation
methods or post-talk explanation methods
in fact if you recall we also saw that
attention weights which falls under our
inherently interpretable models category
those are also not corresponding to
meaningful information that was another
result that we saw right and there are
no studies on Prototype layers uh and
adding them to sort of this whole deep
learning pipelines okay and so which
means at least here exploration is being
done so we know there are issues so
there is there are areas where there is
not even exploration being done and of
course that we'll talk about that a bit
more in you know future research
problems
all right so let's take a look at some
of the theoretical results both for the
analysis of interpretable models
inherently interpretable models and
post-hoc explanations right when it
comes to inherently interpretable models
you'll potentially see like or you'll
predominantly see two main classes of
theoretical results uh the first one is
it's basically about certifying the
optimality of the lists or sets that are
learned using certain procedures right
so if I use my algorithm and generate
such a rule list or such a rule set I
can certify that it will be within this
much of the optimal so that that is one
kinds of theoretical one set of
theoretical results you'll see and there
are also some uh more recent sort of
results on saying that there are no
accuracy interpretability trade-offs in
certain settings that means you can come
up with an interpretable model which is
simple enough and it will also be the
most accurate model but while this is a
good starting point these settings are
rather restrictive for example it's like
RL with small mazes right so in such a
setting people have shown that you know
there are no trade-offs but you know
that's clearly not representative of lot
of real world settings so while there
are preliminary results I think there is
scope to do a lot more in these okay now
let's talk about the theoretical results
on the post hoc explanation method site
so this is one of the papers that I
think kicked off the theoretical
analysis of post-hoc explanation methods
by Gary at all they did this analysis of
a variant of lime called tabular line
which only operates on discrete features
and not on continuous features uh so
what they show is that they obtain close
form Solutions of the average
coefficients output by line okay when
the underlying black box is a linear
model so all these results are just when
the underlying model itself is a linear
model okay
and they also show that the coefficients
obtained are proportional to the
gradient of the function to be explained
again with respect to a linear model and
they show that the local error of the
surrogate model is you know bounded away
from zero with a high probability right
so you know the explanations error is
like bounded away from zero with a high
probability okay all right
um so this is some of our work on
unifying some of these methods uh which
is specifically lime and smooth grad
what we consider is actually a
continuous version of line uh where the
perturbations are happening in a
continuous space and not in a binary
space or a discrete space and we show
that these two methods actually converge
or output the same explanation in
expectation so if we basically have the
ability to generate infinite number of
perturbations and get an explanation
then the resulting explanation would
sort of converge between these methods
okay but you know it's it's not that
pessimistic we can actually get it with
finite samples as well there is also
that result what we also show is that in
expectation the resulting explanations
are probably robust according to the
notion of Lipschitz continuity so
essentially you can give some guarantees
on the stability or robustness of these
explanations in expectation and we also
have finite sample complexity bounds for
the number of perturbed samples or
perturbations required for these two
methods to converge to their expected
output so what is the minimum number of
samples M required for these two methods
to converge to an output result in the
same output so what would that look like
right
so another one of recent works that we
have been involved with and I'm super
excited about this one specifically is
to sort of bring some order to a lot of
these postdoc explanation methods that
are out there right uh so in a very very
recent paper what we show is that
various feature attribution methods and
when I use that word feature attribution
methods it is methods like line
um continuous variant of lime shap and
all the gradient based methods they all
generate some form of feature importance
or feature attribution right so we show
that these are all essentially local
linear function approximations so
they're all trying to do a local linear
function approximation but the reason
they all disagree with each other as we
have been seeing quite a bit in the you
know past hour or so is because they
adopt different loss functions and
different definitions of local
neighborhoods and this is precisely the
different definitions of local
neighborhoods and loss functions that
they adopt uh so this is at least trying
to put some order as to they're all sort
of unified in some ways but at the same
time there are differences because
they're all adopting their own
definition of what loss function to use
and then how to define a local
neighborhood right uh so we also have
something called as a no free lunch
theorem for explanation methods given
that these methods all adopt a
particular definition of what a local
neighborhood looks like uh no single
method can perform optimally across all
neighborhoods because they're all
tailored towards certain definitions of
what a local neighborhood should be
right so this theorem is basically to me
it's interesting and also I think it has
more implications is that every time a
new paper comes out you know people show
the performance that oh this beats it on
everything else right so this result
basically shows that no single method is
going to work across all definitions of
what a local neighborhood is right so
that claim that this method beats
everything at least with respect to you
know certain aspects of it will not hold
because of this theoretical result okay
uh so with that we are at the end of
this module and then we are going to
discuss more about Open problems future
research directions in the next 40
minutes or 45 minutes